hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up
Prince William calls for an end to the
illegal Wildlife trade in his first
speech as the Prince of Wales
meanwhile calls grow for his father to
attend cop 27 despite advice from
Downing Street to stay away
just stop oil protesters bring their
campaign to Westminster as they call for
climate action
foreign
to the Daily climate show where we track
the changes happening to our world and
interrogate some of the potential
solutions to the crime climate crisis
now the Prince of Wales has made his
first speech since being given his new
title and it was on a subject close to
his heart the illegal trade in animals
and plants or Prince William was at the
science museum in central London this
afternoon where he delivered the keynote
speech at the United for wildlife
summits now the event is unveiling new
policies and Global Partnerships to help
end the illegal Wildlife trade which is
worth an estimated 17 and a half billion
pounds every year now that puts it among
the five most lucrative Global crimes
with the trade often run by highly
organized criminal networks now more
than 7 000 species of wild animals and
plants are currently traded illegally
around the world
with up to 100 million individual
animals and plants trafficked annually
thanks to your collaboration and Forward
Thinking our activity is having a
demonstrable impact
and while we do not have the luxury of
time clearly we do have a proven road
map to success
and the motivation to put it into action
I hope you all leave here today
energized and motivated to intensify
this work
because there are still too many
criminals who believe they can act with
impunity
Too Many Lives being destroyed
and too many species on the brink of
Extinction due to this heinous crime
and so I call on all of you here today
and those involved in United for
wildlife further afield
keep breaking the mold
keep Building Bridges and making those
game-changing connections
keep believing that this is a crime that
can be ended once and for all
because I know with your commitment it
can
thank you
Sky News is Royal correspondent Rhianna
Mills was at the summit
well it shouldn't be underestimated the
fact that the new Prince of Wales and
now Earth the throne has decided that
this is the issue that he wants to talk
about in his first speech and it is a
passionate speech where in no uncertain
terms he is talking very clearly about
the dangers of not tackling the illegal
Wildlife trade he talks about how too
many criminals believe they can act with
impunity too many lives are being
destroyed and too many species are on
the brink of Extinction and I think he's
very clearly making that point
emphasizing that yes of course the
destruction of wildlife is really
important but it's also the knock-on
impact the fact that the trade is often
funding serious and organized crime
terrorism around the world and that's
why it's important for both the public
the private sector businesses and
governments all to get together when it
comes to tackling this issue now United
for wildlife that's being talked about
today actually Prince William's been
involved in for six years now and it has
had its successes which told that it's
contributed to 250 arrests at 450 cases
of illegal Wildlife trading and also
trained a hundred thousand people to try
and Tackle this issue but at the center
of it I think again you're seeing how a
member of the royal family is really
important when it comes to being a
convening power getting people around
the table and of course that's something
we've already talked about this week in
the context of we now know that the king
is now no longer going to go to cop 27
of course lots of debate about why
exactly he's decided not to go whether
it was the government who suggested he
shouldn't or whether it was his own team
who thought that it wasn't the right
place for him to go but in terms of
Prince William today I think very
clearly saying that yes his role has
changed yes he is now at the throne and
that may change in some ways what he
feels he can and can't say but certainly
he's going to continue to be a very
passionate campaigner when it comes to
environmental issues
so King Charles won't be there but
plenty of other world leaders will in
the Red Sea Resort of charmel Sheikh
when the next U.N climate Summit begins
on the 6th of November now just 33 days
away and the Egyptian government which
is hosting cop 27 has warned the UK
against backtracking from the global
climate agenda in a significant
intervention prompted by fears over Liz
truss's commitment to Net Zero or
Buckingham Palace says that the decision
for the king not to attend was made
following advice from the Prime Minister
but the chair of the defense select
committee to bias Elwood told Sky news
this morning that the king should
consider going anyway
climate change talking about France is
the biggest threat that we face and we
did such a fantastic job at cop26 and
Prince Charles as he then was played a
pivotal role you know we talk about
Britain's soft power it doesn't come
bigger than our royal family and I do
hope that Common Sense will prevail that
the king will be allowed to attend this
is such an important ly taking place cop
27 and some will shake in Egypt I would
strongly suggest that it isn't just the
king that goes but let's trust the Prime
Minister goes as well and you know
absolutely promotes the idea of global
Britain so what are the chances of the
Prime Minister heading to Egypt for the
summit or joining me now from Birmingham
is Sky's Chief political correspondent
John Craig
um John can we expect a U-turn here
well at the moment we are not expecting
the prime minister to attend this Summit
and of course it has been claimed that
she urged the king the new king not to
go either now that's been disputed by 10
Downing Street who said it would be
ridiculous for the PM to tell the king
what to go to I don't control his diary
Liz trust has said but Tobias Elwood has
made a pretty weighty intervention today
he said that that Charles is a globally
respected voice on the environment and
climate change his attendance would add
serious authority to the British
delegation can we really go from hosting
cop 26 to benching soft power at cop 27.
now the queen did speak at cop 26 in
Glasgow and a lot of environmentalists
we really would like to see King Charles
uh speak at this Summit next month at
the moment doesn't look as though that's
going to happen it doesn't look as
though Liz truss is going to go either
but we may hear more from Liz truss in
her big speech at the end of this
conference tomorrow first of all on her
policy on Net Zero there's been doubts
and fears about the government's
commitment to that and she may have
something to say also about cop 27 but
at the moment it's thought that neither
She nor King Charles will be attending
that Summit
okay John Craig thank you very much
okay time to look at some other stories
making the news now and according to new
research black Asian and other ethnic
minorities in England are more than
three times more likely to live in
neighborhoods with very high air
pollution putting them a
disproportionate risk of heart attacks
cancer and strokes research by friends
of the earth showed that Minority ethnic
people make up nearly half of the
populations living in areas where
average levels as nitrogen dioxide or
particle pollution were double World
Health Organization guidelines
now hundreds of white clawed crayfish
have been relocated as part of a project
to protect the endangered species a
Derbyshire Wildlife truss has led a
scheme to move the native crayfish from
National Trust site kettleston hall now
the species are under threats from
non-native signal crayfish which are
living Downstream and they've
transferred them to a secret location
where it's hoped their numbers can grow
now a campaign group just stop oil is
continuing its protest in Westminster
now the group which is aiming to block
all future licensing of fossil fuel
projects also blocked Four Bridges
across the Thames and has vowed to
return to Westminster every day until
its demands are met for Skies Emma
birchley has been talking to some of the
protesters
well we're currently walking down the
middle of Whitehall which has been
blocked by the Civil resistance campaign
group just stop oil they have launched
an Autumn of action and urging people to
gather at 11AM every day at Downing
Street for this kind of protest blocking
the traffic civil resistance I'm joined
Now by Alex De kerning who's one of
these uh the the supporters and
spokespeople of this group and tell me I
mean what's the point of this why are
you blocking Whitehall
um history has shown that in order to
get the radical change that we need at
on the time scale that we have civil
resistance is the best form of method
and of course there's an enormous amount
of frustration for people though people
beeping their horns you know they are
angry because they can't get to where
they need to be they might have
important places to go of course yeah
but I'm not a politician I don't need to
rely on votes I need to rely on
popularity all I want is change to
happen because if we don't get changed
things like 33 million people being
flooded in Pakistan and being displaced
from their homes that's going to come
more and more frequent by eight years
the heat wave that India and Pakistan
happened had and where it was so hot
that birds fell out of the sky and
thousands upon thousands people died
that's gonna start happening and over 90
of countries every second year and just
eight years time we have eight years of
oil and Reserve this has never been a
better time to transition it was 40
degrees in London so hot the train track
spontaneously combusted so there was
floods here so people couldn't get to
work
um London Heathrow had his tarmac melted
so planes couldn't take off there's so
many forms of disruption from the
climate crisis but the media only ever
focus on this kind of disruption we're
only going to be here for a short amount
of time the people who are being really
affected are the people who the people
in Pakistan for example 33 million
people six times population of Scotland
my country have just permanently
disrupted and displaced from their homes
it's just when we put things into
context and we realize how little the
government is doing and how much that
they could be doing there's almost no
reason why everybody shouldn't be here
on the streets right now we're here
outside the houses of Parliament how do
you make them MPS in their Listen by
coming back here every single day
demanding change because that is what we
need we're going to be here for at least
a month please come and join us okay
Alex thank you very much yeah so more
protests planned until about the middle
of November
and I'm virtually there and finally four
women have been selected to run the
world's most remote post office in
Antarctica they beat 6 000 other
applicants to manage the historic site
for five months and not only will they
be dealing with freezing temperatures
almost constant daylight and no running
water they'll also share the island with
a colony of penguins and they'll have to
count them too
for me I'm an adventurer I love the
outdoors I love nature I've worked all
my life and to preserve these natural
spaces and the opportunity to go south
and to see this environment is unique
and something that I've been looking
forward to Forever
well that's all for today thanks very
much for watching we'll see you soon